i run a sustainability company
i'm here today to improve my life i
guess
this year has been been a really tough
year
it is real
dion nice to meet you man what do you
want to change i mean you look quite a
fit slender man to be honest mate i need
to improve my mental focus
from my end you come to the beast
mansion to get beasted
and trust yeah you are going to get
beasted this is my team
these two are my right left hand men
my dad at the time and his wife they
they separated
i stayed live with my stepmom sort of a
short period after
wasn't the best stepson at the time i
was going out i was partying i'd found
drugs at the time
i came back one evening and my my
clothes and
sessions were packed i lost my job as a
result of the drugs
i got into the council accommodation
went to college scraped through
went off to university it was that
summer when
my dad tried to deal with his issues in
his own way that he thought was right at
the time
he ended up a very poorly boy in
hospital at the time
and yeah
without the time by by not really
talking about it actually
it popped up again this year right and
we spoke about it
we're better for opening up and talking
about it so it's fair to say you've been
from you've been through it man i mean
there's not a lot of people that get
chucked out of their house at 16 17
years old
and come out shining with a wife three
children as a successful businessman
[Music]
[Applause]
good spot on come on
stop slacking get back in come on let's
go
that's it head up mate let's see
taylor's push down it's fine
well done buddy
let's go faster
there's one more thing i want to do
before you go that's the before picture
facing forward
thanks guys awesome thank you very much
you've been a star okay well done dude
take care man he was a nice guy yeah
awesome mate i mean at the beginning i
got a little bit choked up because i
really connected with his story there's
a lot of similarities between his life
and
my life life puts these things at you as
tests and as lessons
and he's obviously learned from these
lessons and because of those lessons
he's where he is now with his wife and
his kids with his successful business
that's a wrap i'm happy with that guys
let's get it
it's food time yeah so you're having
rabbit food again
yeah yeah
yesterday was fantastic today
it's been really tough i had to go into
the gym let's see what
see what i can get done today
[Music]
just finished day one workout i feel a
million times better than when i did
the first day of meal prep two sets of
cashews there i've
got two portions of chicken
[Music]
today i'm on a low carb day i've been
feeling a bit hungry but at the same
time
i've had more energy levels right so the
gym finished early tonight
so i couldn't do my concept too brewing
so instead
i came for doing a jog it's the first
time i've done a good run in years
it was really good to begin out on my
feet
[Music]
welcome to the house thank you very much
morning hello
nice to meet you are you going all right
in general with the day is it you had a
little wobble this weekend
i was just starving the kids had and the
wife had a kebab so i had a bit of a
bit of a lamb donna i've been really
good up until that point
so i was just kind of crashing yeah i
didn't have the strength to
to say no firstly thanks being honest
because a lot of people have said now
everything's been bow on and then when
you've picked a bit more of them are not
well actually
this part you can't hit that that that
motivation i do understand that
but it is only six weeks the first week
or so he was
hangry sort of snapping at the smallest
of things
the kids keep trying to eat his food
it's good
but at the same time daddy only gets a
small amount
thank you for that food here yeah i'm
feeling more
more positive about opening up he's now
become a bit more open
about life yeah it has improved since
then i'm
really grateful for the opportunity to
open up to to you guys in the team
so we've just come out of his in dion
looks great opened the door immediate
change looks fantastic he's also really
positive
and really determined and wants to do
well
that sunday normally have a nice family
roast dinner
and we still are having a nice roast
beef dinner wow
i say we i've cooked it for the wife and
the kids and
i'm not gonna be eating it what's daddy
gonna go do now
gym why do we exercise because it keeps
you healthy
it does doesn't it your muscles show
them tensor
big ones look at those muscles
hey dion how are you buddy are you
eating i am indeed
i'm on my chicken arriving hey join the
club buddy how's everything going mate
all right
yeah yeah really good thanks really good
how's the workout doing are you sticking
to it pretty well is it are you finding
it tough
no i'm absolutely loving the workout i
can't even diet so
how much weight have you lost in total
have you been weighing yourself the
first
and second ones that i did i think i
lost five kilos that's good
well listen buddy uh it's been a
pleasure talking to you but i just want
to say good luck with everything
it sounds as though you're doing great
bore the kebab one slip-up's all right
but i don't want any more
okay all right man you take care good
luck with it
i've just spoke to dion he's going
through some troubles you know he's
obviously had a lot of demons in his
past and i feel like he's dragging them
with him in life
you can see there's a lot of a lot of
passion there
but he doesn't quite know which
direction to put the passion so
beyond one of the most worrying ones for
me
went to the gym session today feeling
feeling pretty good actually
overall i think the program the
challenge is going really well so far
it's part of outside opening up to
people a little bit as well around the
mental health side of things
you're stronger person for talking about
these things you know not not the other
way around
it's nice to meet you all tell me guys
how's the undone good
good what about the food have you been
participating in the diet or you've been
eating your chicken nuggets and chips
uh well we've just been trying to tell
him do your job
yeah he's done it all himself have you
helped him have you no i've done it all
you've done it all i thought yeah yeah
you pretty confidently stuck to it
or has it been cheating is it any
cheating whatsoever no
no
what about you dad what'd you think of
it all i'm surprised he stuck at it
yeah i don't think i could have done you
guys ready to get down there see what he
can do
yeah yeah i've lifted a weight before oh
that's it then fully prepped if you've
left it one way you've done them all
[Music]
feeling really well getting there
feeling bad good
feeling a lot better kind of feeling
more like an inner calming piece
it's 86 and a half today just over 14
body fat right well this was nothing
better than let's
stop into the test eh yeah let's get it
on the shoulder press right then
so last time you only got four reps
so we've got four reps to beat so it's
down to you buddy
all right let's get it going come on
guys
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that's it you know that was a
phenomenal
yes yes the fact you've lost weight and
we haven't decreased the weight
on the shoulders make phenomenal there's
one more thing we need from your mate
and that's the
we did the before picture now we need
the after picture
gather around guys it's amazing when you
see him actually side by side
see the difference yeah you can see his
ribs more shoulders more
i'll tell you what you notice the more
the smile throughout this experience
i've been trying to work as hard as i
can and set an example to
myself to my friends my family you know
to my dad and others around me
i feel it's brought everyone closer
together my dad's talking about sort of
doing more exercise now and he calls me
when he's done sort of a big walk or
something
i know he's come a long way with his own
demons and personal issues
which has then inspired me to tackle
mine and just open up and be honest
right dionna mega impressed me guys what
you think
yeah brilliant awesome dude well deon
you came to me to get beasted and you
definitely have been dead
you